we learned that in fact we had
strategic adversaries whose goal
was the destabilization of our
democratic systems is one of the
most important means used by his
adversaries practice either russia
or other countries
and well it is the  direct or
indirect financing of political parties that
aim to destabilize institutions
[Music]
I knew
[Music
] France
we have good who is terrestrial broadband
is the host of things happen
of activity scandal cattle stream
freedom party mix trimaille delegate
patrick rotman epps foreman
races sausages nationally reformed the
pen ou and first kong connection between
chain will have sausage pottal
fii inside and politician is
right there by monsters of
systemic great determination
the quine double quine
peace moose rivals and well the
heliotrope defender to have swiped at
stern unmentored conditions
then there are different ways in
you have the case of the
national rally in
france moreover the case of a loan decided by
a russian bank close to the kremlin
and therefore there it is direct financing
but in the form of a bank loan
you also have indian financing
and qd  we saw it in the campaign on
brazil where in fact nominees tab
were hired by the russians to
finance
the breakbeat campaign we also have examples of
financing by third party, that is to
say that for example in germany  it is
possible for a third party to
campaign on behalf of another party you
have for example the afd which will not be
financed directly but which can
benefit from the support in its campaigns
of a completely unknown organization
whose financing is completely at the
bac and who are campaigning in fact for
the afd so it is indirect campaign
of polished diamonds harmonizing the
various national legislations il
fatto cassimir different rules of
various
igualda  d thomas de gendt financier min
to politics as and the chain this party
has cash available
to alistair does not see the woods and all
larry pope interest kenson lyn thériault
special prizes well coached sporting
transparency and our forests man is coming
sec 1/  10 tnt and harmonist minimum
standing andy is clear redhead is true
that our formations
[Music]